alors je viens de
prendre la photo il y a quelques minutes que
c'est c'est la meilleure façon de faire les
choses ce sera l'avenir c'est
comme ça que
nous si vous voulez revenir à ces
dimanches soirs aller dans une pizzeria
alors c'est le  un peu plus près c'est comme ça que
vous revenez à la normale
je suis vraiment excité de retourner à l'école
à plein temps
et de pouvoir jouer à nouveau dans un groupe
normalement
je suis vraiment excité de revoir mes amis
et de ne pas avoir à me soucier de
donner à chacun  d'autres clans,
donc cela soulage un peu le stress
[Musique]
donc aujourd'hui, nous avons probablement environ trois
fois plus de personnes qui viennent et
se font vacciner qu'hier,
donc les chiffres ont beaucoup augmenté aujourd'hui
et je suppose que c'est beaucoup  des
jeunes qui viennent se faire
vacciner [Musique]
[Musique] on
dirait qu'il a été ouais